you've been Drake drinking the urine 24
years the coveted vaccines have only
been around a couple years prior to the
covid vaccines what did the urine do for
you now you're saying it protects you
from the coveted vaccine but before the
covet vaccine what did the urine do for
you again as I told you earlier and I
don't remember if you understood or
heard that it's the perfect photonic
memory of when the cells were healthy so
I believe any poison that comes in the
temple the temple creates antibodies the
liver spins it and you piss it out and I
believe one of the best things you can
do is take it back in not to mention it
is billions and billions of stem cells
do you understand you've already drink
your own urine David do you understand
that when you're in your mother's womb
you drink your own urine did you
understand that or no no that's not my
understanding of uh mammalian gestation